[موسيقى]
تعد محميه السلاحف في راس الحد بولايه
الصور واحده من اهم المعالم السياحيه
المميزه في سلطنه عمان وتحتل مساحه 120 كم
مربعا من اراضي ساحليه وعلى امتداد الساحل
الذي يبلغ طوله حوالي 40 كيلو مترا وتضم
هذه المحميه اكثر من 20,000 سلحفاه لانواع
مختلفه لذلك اطلقت هيئه البيئه العمانيه
برنامج ترتل الكوماندوز لحمايه ومراقبته
ورصد السلاح في البحريه
لهذه الثروه الطبيعيه اللي هي السلاحف
البحريه لان من اصل سبعه انواع سلاحف
بحريه في العالم سلطنه عمان تزورها خمسه
انواع فهذا يعني يجعل سلطنه عمان من اهم
ثلاث مواقع في العالم همم للسلاحف هذا
البرنامج يسعى الى حمايه هذه السلاحف من
خلال رفع مستوى الوعي المجتمعيه تغيير
سلوك الافراد تجاه هذه الكائنات من اهداف
برنامج
هي توعيه المجتمع خاصه المجتمع المحلي
باهميه السلاحف البحريه لانها كونها انها
ثروه طبيعيه تسخر فيها سلطنه عمان كذلك
همم تشجيع فئه الشباب على التطوع البيئي
نظافه الشواطئ من اهداف الحمله والشباب
متطوعين الاشاركونا يقوم همم تنظيف
ايضا الى تشجيعي فئه الشباب على التطوع
البيئي وذلك من خلال مشاركه المئات من
المتطوعين في البرامج المتنوعه لحمايه
السلاحف التي اصبحت مهدده بالانقراض بسبب
مخلفات البلاستيك على الشواطئ والتلوث
البيئي عبد الرحمن العصيمي من ولايه الصور
العربيه